well it's a crazy city filled with crazy
people let's let's talk about some of
the nuttiest so folks so Gotham ended
neither of us were that happy with the
last season but we both still of the
show here and there so like yours will
be a little more technically complete
but there's of the characters they
introduced I was I saw them all and I
just didn't really care about it yeah no
they weren't it was a weak way to him
but we both loved the show we both loved
these characters and so to have fun and
feel like we're closing this out on a
better note than the show itself gave
we're doing a top 10 list and we're
doing this the same way we did in the
Buffy video last year which is that we
both have our top 10s we have them on
flash cards we do not know the other
ones top tens and we're just kind of
reveal them as we go along and you also
have a bunch of honorable mentions but
we're not god I'm not gonna front-load
with those we will tackle those will
tackle the honorable mentions I think
when we get to maybe that right before
we do the top three will do your
honorable mentions okay okay because
because otherwise it's gonna take us
forever to get started we just mentioned
how you gave me a list of like I don't
know 30 40 and I think Devin 225 yep
gonna be hard and then I was like oh I
got to 18 now and then I stayed stuck on
13 for a long time this has been a
process to get hurt and any and if you
haven't been around for one of our lists
before she not only has the names on the
index card she has notes on the back of
them I do not oh yeah there's some where
I'm like I need I need more note cards
first okay so there's ready with your
number 10 yep all right here we go ah oh
yeah you like her better I do
yeah I know you really like her I did so
I mean I'll mention this fish mooney was
one of my early hook ins cuz I was not a
huge fan of I didn't like the pilot
episode at all and it took me a little
while to get into the first season and
there were basically two things that
kept me coming back in those early
episodes one was Oswald Cobblepot the
other was fish Mooney and I really think
Jada Pinkett Jada pinkett-smith brought
a great presence to the proceedings she
felt like she really she was there to
play and she she was she fun she was
having fun and she felt very in command
and yet and in a way that made it very
cathartic when she got bumped out of her
seat of power so I it like she occupies
the very bottom spot because like she's
not like she barely makes the number-10
and part of it is like grandfather Klaus
didn't because I I may not have stuck
with this show if it wasn't for you and
a couple of other people so I feel like
I needed to give her a mention there
that's fair I like her um she it took me
a while to get into her she was just a
little and it I mean Gotham like that
first season especially like you you had
to figure it out
it takes a while to get on its wave I
fear for me that's why and by the time I
got injured then she was gone and I was
like well it's fair enough and she came
up briefly but like again like nomina I
do like her though and like I do think
it was she was having a blast in that
role so we could talk about yours good
yeah butch but um and as and that does
include Solomon Grundy I could have done
them as separate characters you gave
them to me as both but like he does kind
of go back to being butch yeah like I
feel like it is different phases of the
same characters even though like the
behavior is different it's it's not like
some other characters that might come up
later on the list where it feels more
proper to section them off like I I
stand behind lumping butch with Solomon
Grundy which is actually part of why he
didn't make my list because like if he
had just had his butch Ark and had been
closed out and spoilers by the way in
season 3 weather
out this show yeah when he got killed he
might have made my top ten I didn't
dislike the Solomon Grundy Ark but I
kind of felt like he worked better as
much as butch I will give you that I
liked it because here's the thing he's
constantly getting manipulated and he
works really well for that I he's a good
supporting character he's a really good
supporting character and that's why he's
on my list he's just kind of this enigma
of a character that's kind of a sweet
chumpy guy but still totally capable of
double-crossing you murdering oh yeah
all that galore he fits really well into
the Gotham underworld has a really
complex relationship with penguin where
they're constantly like allies and then
double-crossing each other and then like
you know okay kind of friends but also
not really because nobody's friends for
a while yeah that's this area lies
I really would do like his relationship
with Tabitha that that was well
developed like initially when they
started hinting at that I was like wait
what but no that that worked well and
kind of kinky and kind of dysfunctional
and it's very Gotham way yeah they're an
item now barf
yes I'm sure we will be we'll get there
yeah so yep yeah I just really like him
again I agree with you Solomon Grundy is
not as bad but what I did like about
that character was that it was Tabitha
trying to get through to him even if it
meant she was beating the crap out of
him a varied awesome way to go about
bringing back the person you love ya
know hit them and if that doesn't work
hit them again and then and then maybe
electrocuted
yeah honestly both with him and with
Tabitha I'm like I'm sorry to see you go
but I'm like probably it's not a bad
thing you know you miss the kind of a
mess so yeah you didn't miss much by
accident
a little bit earlier fair enough so
number nines got yours yep
okay here we go okay I'm you can talk
about Barbara I'm gonna hold my because
spoiler Barbara's on my list but a lot
higher so I'll talk about her a little
later um so when she's good when she's
having like when she is in full Barbra
mode she's just great the creepy eyes be
she and tabby are great together I love
their Hulk nightclub I love what they do
I like her relationship with Selena and
the relation and the Alliance she and
Selena and tabby have um I like how she
and Lee and Jim are co-parenting at the
end I do like her obsession with Jim
throughout she is I don't like jealousy
in real life but it works so well on
Gotham what it works well with her and
there's another character that you'll
see much higher on my list where I'm
like yeah jealousy works for you here's
what here's what I liked about her in
the in that jealousy angle I'm gonna
mention here because I might forget to
mention it when she shows up on my list
is that it was like initially it was a
very active jealously I'm gonna break
you thing but what I like is season 3
onward it was just an undercut she was
just operating on the presumption like
oh you're gonna end up with me
eventually I don't I don't need to even
do much because I know that's what's
gonna happen I like that that was an
undercurrent to her interactions with
him I love the occasion and she just
always looked fabulous oh my god so much
and then I like there was not a bad
hairstyle on that woman like they could
do anything with her hair she's just
great
that being said she's not higher for me
because again it took me a while to get
into her she's kind of like a flat
character before before she goes nuts
before she gets tortured and then I
didn't really like the Ra's al Ghul's
storyline
no fair there are a few dips in her
character or else she would have been
higher on my way she's another one that
like they found a few good things to do
with her later she's another one that
might have been better leaving her dead
at the end of season 3 hmm
yeah but well also I mean let's be
honest
bisexual blonde solidarity yeah yeah
represent okay um so my number 9 I have
to go strange mmm-hmm
I'm gonna start talking about him cuz
he's my number 8 so ok I'll go right
after you okay cool um so like what I
liked about him is they did because Hugo
Strange
in the comics can be you can be an odd
one to deal with depending on how you
choose to motivate him because the ways
written he's usually either motivated
like strictly as a mad scientist or as
like somebody who's basically a madman
for hi-oh like doing stuff for money
I think they rode the line really well
here where he is very interested in his
experiments in his results but he's also
a total coward and and like what he has
a coward with zero morals so what he was
like
like his appearance disease by what he
pops up just happens to be putting chips
into people because somebody's paying
him to do it like oh yeah that tracks
that's totally the kind of thing that he
would do um and bTW Wong is just smooth
oh yeah yep that was it for me
it was like that voice that ventas lee
that does help a lot because I think the
most exposure I got into like I knew
Hugo Strange but I think the most
exposure I got into him prior to this
was the animated series and he was much
more of a shouty kind of a character
they're much know I like the smooth
thing like even even when he's panicking
he's still smooth he's probably leading
my favorite voice on Gotham where I'm
just like a ha ha what's up he's your
number 8 so I'll go ahead and talk about
yes I already am so he's my number eh I
like how much he sets in motion a lot of
the plot that he has made Arkham what it
is he brings back a lot of great
characters fish and Jerome and at one
point I don't like theo galavan you
won't see him on my list but he also did
bring him back so - yes sir extent yeah
and he also souped up a whole bunch of
characters Firefly yeah was what she was
because of Hugo Strange so he's just a
great performance great just great
use in terms of developing other
characters um I wish you would have been
around more I think or he would and he
would have maybe been higher in my list
had he been around in more seasons see
the thing is I'm not sure you could
build too much more than you did then
you did around him because he doesn't
have a grand plan and he's too
self-serving yeah but I will never get
tired of here in that voice fair enough
so that was your number eight so my
number eight and you'll know what this
means but I need to explain this to
viewers so middle IV so IV pepper
this shows version of poison ivy
basically appears in three and I
consider them completely different
distinct forms we have her introduced
initially as a young girl mm-hmm she
then gets artificially aged up and like
and there's an in-universe explanation
for that and we get my favorite IV which
is middle IV later should have been me
only I know don't know why they gave us
third I I know they did third IV who was
like it was a totally valid execution of
poison ivy as a character but I liked
middle I be so much more what I liked
about her was they especially given the
fact that a big part of her deal is that
people men mostly are innately attracted
to her and given that she still has the
mind of a child that could have come off
super creepy but it never did for two
reasons the first is yes they're all men
kind of become obsessed with him but
they also listen to her so she's never
in danger from them and two she still
has a at the middle IV stage she still
has a very innocent perception of sex so
like she's
like never depicted as having sex with
any no no like middle IB despite looking
very attractive is not a sexualized
character it's very obvious that people
have that attraction to it but she's
just kind
oh yeah but just do what I want now it's
great that she still had that naivete
going on
she's just charming she's on my
Honorables mentions list I think she
would have she was like one of the on my
13 where I'm like I want to I think it's
just if they had kept her and
incorporated her more she would have
gotten on my list but like if they had
kept her around instead of upping her
again into the last I do we got yeah she
might have been higher for me but I had
a lot of fun with middle IV which was
nice because conceptually when I found
out that was what they were doing I'm
like that's stupid
and then I saw her like that's awesome
she was a nice surprise
um yeah oh and I really liked that scene
with penguin where she's helping him out
like that that that whole scene ah yeah
she's great with penguin as many
characters oh all right so we're at
number 7 yes so ready yep Oh higher
tabby and I've got Alfred Pennyworth
so you started talking about tabby
earlier so um I I really was not
expecting her to die and the the the
first episode of the fifth season that
hurt I really liked her I loved her
whole dynamic and love triangle with
Barb and Butch that's a lot of fun
like I said sweet relationship with
butch little dysfunctional good like a
little bit but like that's Gotham she
kind of works as a dominatrix I mean
part of it is this is my you're so hot
like you wear leather and carry around
whips and that makes me happy fair that
is fair I do love this
Club and just that whole ladies club and
you can just tell like they're just
sometimes like especially when they pull
Celine ends the mix they're just like
we're so done with the boys I did like
her role I didn't like that barb was
with Ra's al Ghul but I did like how she
kind of pulled her out of that yeah so I
did like her role in that storyline even
though I didn't really like the
storyline I liked her role in it oh um I
like that she trained Selina and gets
her kind of into being more of the
Catwoman um and I you know there's not a
lot of people in color of color on
Gotham and that's true
and I mean I mean part of that is there
honestly aren't a lot of people color in
Batman mythos broadly speaking visit
she's an original character she is an
original character right so is face yeah
so like like in Batman and Batman lore
properly in Batman lore proper there's
Lucius Fox that's find it what about Lee
Lee while first of all Lee in the comics
is is well I guess I was gonna say
significantly or older I guess she's
about Gordon's age so like well yeah
gray-haired old gray-haired old white
lady is Lee in the comics okay yeah so
um yeah and she's just tough and hot and
like just like the moment she came on
the scene I'm like you know I do I
really do like tabby and there is never
like really a dip in her character like
there are that's true that's a lot of
these kind of come and go up and down
and that's honestly like I'll mention
Selena as
I will mention but she just had too many
like ups and downs for me
yes Selena didn't make my list either
yeah but anyway so Alfred yeah I will
speak a little bit about him but yeah
he's higher on my list
yeah so well first of all I'm just a
sucker for Sean Pertwee yeah I love him
as an actor I love his I love his his
rough and tumble energy that he has I
love the sense of authority when he
speaks he got beaten up a lot
holy cow more concussions than a
linebacker dang taking bullets like he
is he is gritty but what I like is I
mean amongst other things one of the
things I like is that he has to learn
how to deal with Bruce because you know
we've always seen Alfred after having
had already raised Bruce so usually when
we see Alfred and Bruce they already
have that father-son dynamic whereas
here they're still figuring out he does
not seamlessly slip into being a
surrogate father figure it's rough for
him too and I like that and I like that
as much as Bruce who didn't make my list
for the record but who I did enjoy as
much as Bruce is figuring out his own
path Alfred is also figuring out how his
path relative to Bruce and how to best
support Bruce while still trying to keep
him from going down worst paths than
he's already on so I really thought the
the dynamic and the growth of that
relationship especially it was really
good yes you will see him later there
higher on my list okay I'll say a few
more things about him then okay so
number six
oh he's yeah you will see this guy yeah
I knew he was gonna be higher for you
yeah so leave I always liked her um and
I like the up-and-down parts of her
relationship with Gordon that she always
has some kind of hold and sway on him
even when she's with Mario and he's with
Valerie for a little while
I did like that but I liked her best
when she had no connection with him and
was just running the Narrows honestly uh
yes that would get today that was my
favorite version
yes she's great with Bullock as well oh
yeah she really is like they have a good
relationship and you know he all Harv
always understands her pull on me and
like how that can influence him
she calls Gordon on his stuff yes
so I'm not afraid somebody needs to yes
I really think that they handled the
heartache and her fury at losing Mario
really well which professor yes into
season four Lee which is most improved
character in a single season season four
leaves the best lady her as like an
underworld boss as Queen of the Narrows
is just great
like darkly is a lot of fun yes and I
really do love her affair with Edie -
and where I love the - enough stabbing
each other there's so much I love it so
much and I think not be with you know
penguin which I ship so hard Lea that
totally like best toys scenario if he
has to be heterosexual Lee Lee Lee
barely missed my list really she did not
make sure you did not make it she was
close she was really close but it was
because of how long it took me to really
love her because I really kind of only
loved loved her in season four and I
didn't dislike her prior to that she was
just kind of there yeah um so like if I
did an honorable mentions list which I
didn't she would have been on there
there so Oswald who likes that I knew
was gonna be much higher on your list
now like I'll say first the reason why I
don't have him higher was something that
you already mentioned which is that sort
of up-and-down thing and the thing with
Oswald is he was one of my early hook
ins like fish he was one of the things
early on they kept me coming back and I
love what an opportunist he is and I do
think there's a lot of validity to
reason they had him kind of going up and
down and his see in Gotham which is that
he's very good at getting to the top
he's very bad at running things once
he's there because he only knows how to
be ruthless and ruthless can get you
there but ruthless does not run an
efficient operation once you're in
charge so it's totally valid but
definitely by the end of season
Forrester season five I was really tired
of seeing him ascend at the top fall
back down ascend to the top fall back
down I was just really tired of the of
that repetition even though I understood
it was basing character and made a lot
of sense so the reason he's not higher
is because I got irritated at sort of
the repetition of the character use but
I I do enjoy him as a character I love
that he is he's just so bad at people he
is terrible at relating to be he's not
even very good at manipulating people
but he always happens to have something
that they need and he jumps on every
opportunity so fast he's not gonna make
it I will not say a lot until I get to
him but yeah you will we will get I I do
enjoy
Oswald a lot it was just that was an
issue where the character use brought
him down just a little bit I will I will
have my rebuttal to that oh yeah okay so
number five ah ah so you want to take it
oh yes sure I just enjoy watching him
struggle and throughout um that struggle
between IDI and the Riddler and like who
am I gonna blame it on this week well I
like that the Riddler is just as likely
to get mad at Eddie as ed is to get mad
at the Riddler I like that that cut both
ways
yeah they did it really well the actor
is great um watching him devolve is
fascinating again ship him and
yes I look here's the thing the one
reason I'm not mad at them for that
because in my head Canon Oswald's
asexual yeah so like I'm okay but like
the two of you put the two of them in a
room together and I love that scene I
don't care what episode is it I don't
care what's going on put them in the
same room and I love it if they are at
each other's throats trying to kill each
other or like brokering or an alliance
or if Ozzy is pining for him I am just
happy whenever they're together or the
most touching thing ever them going for
a hug each prepared to stab the other in
the back of the neither one does it I
really like watching the other
characters sort of learn to mistrust him
and I love putting him at Gotham City
Police and how his relationship kind of
corrodes with Harvey and Lee and Gordon
yeah so that's fun and just like some of
the things that Lee says to him you know
once she knows about Chris some words I
don't love the Kristen kringles
storyline or the Isabella stuff he has
until he it was unnecessary it was bad
choices and women and I always and this
is an issue I have I love Tyrion in Game
of Thrones I have issues with him
killing Shae I have issues once again
and I think partially I
my mother was someone who worked in the
criminal justice system and I would hear
stories of domestic violence growing up
so it's always something that just is
like I can't handle no that's that's
fair I would say like I feel like the
Kristen Kringle thing made a little bit
more sense in terms of getting him to
that sort of de-evolution into someone
like the Riddler reviving that with the
Isabella thing that was completely
unnecessary but I do I do get
you're saying brought nothing no she
wasn't great she just and like that was
that was an issue I had early on with
Gotham was the first season or so other
than Selina cuz I like Selina early on
it was a lot of women being victims it
was a bit and then it got better I think
that was also one of the reasons I liked
fish yes um so I'd like anything
nygma was my four so that you want to
say any more no I mean I think we've
we've got it Ed's just EDS Edie and ed
is a lot of fun yeah um so coming
backwards to my number five then so
Harvey he was I did not fall in love
with him as quickly as I did with
someone like fish or someone like Oswald
but he was a good steady presence
through some of the rough parts of the
show he could be counted on did you two
just be the oh for God's sake yeah like
he was the Oh Gotham guy and he was
really good for that Donal Logue is he's
just a good presence I always enjoy him
even when he's in things that are not
very good he is pretty much always
enjoyable and he had a he had a really
good dynamic with with Jim Gordon he had
a good dynamic with pretty much
everybody but he was with Jim the most
so that was that was kind of essential
since especially the early seasons were
built on that relationship um and he he
also you know he has his own little mini
arcs he he faces consequences he is in
charge at one point and blows it and
that wrecks him for a bit and so he as
much as he is a supporting character
who's a supporting character afforded
growth and also stumbling as he went
which was nice because they could they
could have just kept him at the same
note he started at and just had him be
the snarky detective Ben left it at that
but they didn't they put more than
effort than that into it and I
appreciated it yes so my number four was
Edie who was your number four Carole
Jerome Valeska um so I don't know
anything much of him when they
introduced him and see
come on oh look at he's okay whatever
it's when he comes back in season two si
oh okay now we're having fun um just the
cult following
it just works really well he's he's so
crave that grin Oh God um just the way
he messes with Bruce and his obsession
with him and you just don't know what
he's gonna do I love how he holds sway
other over other villains like echo and
touching scarecrow and how he can
manipulate them he's just so much fun he
is it is and like it's worth actually
for it
he's my three so I like him and I like
him way better than Jeremiah Jeremiah is
not on my list Jeremiah would wouldn't
even get an honorable mention on my list
I don't play on mine either he's not a
bad Jeremiah is not bad it's just like
we had yes we had Jerome we didn't need
Jeremiah we had Jerome but I love that
he he just wants to have fun and his
idea of fun is so messed up and that's
what I love about it is that he he
obviously puts some degree of planning
but the plenty he puts in seems to be
more for showmanship than for function
it's much more about making a spectacle
than actually accomplishing anything and
he's he's kind of the epitome of Gotham
yeah he is he is like okay not only am I
gonna do this thing I'm gonna make a
show of doing this do not make sense but
man are we gonna have fun yes like
that's that is Jerome in a nutshell like
this doesn't need to me makes sense cuz
it's fun so I like come on so he was
also my number three but before we get
to your number three and then up from
there let's do your honorable mentions
how many do you have
go go ahead we'll try not to stay on
them too long both okay so Gertrude
Cobblepot oh good
well that's that's just because Carol
Kane yeah that's pretty much it
girl cane she is like I mean she's just
great she's just doting and Daffy and
wonderful and a little clueless and
she's Carole King I mean if you were
gonna show
Oswald's mother that's really who it had
to be yeah um Selena I want to mention
um I do like her a lot first season I do
like many of her bits of her
relationship with Bruce she works again
great with tabby and yep I will never be
tired of her with tabby and Barb she
just had too many like ups and down I
don't like this storyline and other done
now she's being bratty and it's just
like that it was a character uneven
she's one of those characters that I
think they they ran out of good ideas
for her by the end of season three again
and the actress does a good job I do
want to give a shout out to James Gordon
not on my list
think he's a great protagonist um like
to watch him kind of fall apart and
build himself back up and just struggle
with himself constantly considering that
he is more or less the straight man they
were able to get a bit more out of him
than I would have expected out of the
guy who needs to be the steady presence
and the guy who's from the OC yeah yeah
you or no like you were like the bad boy
on a silly like I'm so so I'm like I'm
like I'm liking you here you have grown
as an actor you have been braced the
like nerdy craziness like so I like that
so I kudos to Ben McKenzie um middle IV
middle wannabe bar you're talking about
again she is the best Ivy hands down
there should not be another ivy yeah um
touch yes so I love Mad Hatter mainly
because of his influence on Gordon and
how he unravels him you know in
flute-like you know that choice he makes
between Lee and Valerie like he just
really messes with Gordon and I joy he's
good for that and then Victor Zsasz um
again he would have been my 11 cuz I
like I was down to like who's my number
10 and
was like Nathaniel like dad's on your
list and you're like yeah I was like
okay then we will talk about him it will
be fine he's just that grin and that
like he just takes such glee such glee
and murdering people the man loves his
work he really does no I are more than
enough of him for me so that was the
main thing so those are my honorable
mentions I narrowed it down from like 10
plus 2 6 so we should be like there's
two that I didn't do an honorable
mention list but I do want to mention to
people real quick because I didn't put
them in consideration because they have
short-run appearance but they were both
really good one was the pig I thought he
was great I think he did a great little
mini Ark the other literally only had
one episode but I had I still wanted her
to come and that is Laurie Petty's
character from season 2 from that this
ball of money meanness as sort of this
proto Harley Quinn I love her so much
and the interrogation that Gordon tries
to have with her it he like gets in her
face like do you want me to hurt you she
just looks at him would you
I've got nowhere else to be Oh God
probably you're fit one of your favorite
lines and Gotha oh that's a great line
and I mean kind of like how for you you
have to give us a shout out to Oswald
Ron because Carol Kane I have to get a
fish shout out to that character because
Laurie patty yeah that's fair no totally
legit so my number three was Jerome we
already did him what's your number three
number three Alfred wavering between him
and she he was originally two now he's
three because they did watch like part
of an episode and I'm like I'm liking
you and making this character um so that
voice again I'm not quite be be wrong
voice but oh that voice that British
accent oh just that like just I didn't
love this version of Alfred a hands-down
favorite version of Alfred just grizzled
tough old British man like bruiser - the
champ you know checkered past like and I
loved his connection to Bruce his father
um he's like a retired jaded James Bond
I feel like a little bit yeah that's
that's the vibe I get from um I like his
connection to Celina that he'll
sometimes be like hey Bruce you're being
a jerk to Selina you're not really
understanding her like you got he's
really sticks up for her I don't think
he trusts Selina but he knows that she
has value and when Bruce screws up he's
like um dude come on
yeah yeah um he works well and scenes
with Gordon and Bullock oh yeah
so the I mean that's the thing about
this cast is like they work so well
together like there's certain characters
where it's like you put this character
in a scene with anyone and it's gonna be
great um and he's a good moral compass
for Bruce because Bruce is a mess for my
series yeah and yeah I just really like
him enjoy him
all right so top two and once you see my
number two you'll know what my number
one is but we'll get there so number two
okay Babs so this like in the she is
right up there in terms of characters
who I initially hate and I mean hated oh
I know I lose Tom and then she went nuts
and then I was like oh my god this is
amazing
like end of season one and the season
one I was still skeptical because I was
like was this the only way they could
make her interesting but then starting a
season two I was like oh oh yes oh she
is so much fun and you're right she was
not always used well and summed like I
didn't love the Ra's al Ghul storyline I
have mixed feelings about the fact that
the last episode makes it look like she
mellowed in later years I mixed feelings
about that cuz on the one hand I can
attest to the fact that having a kid
kind of mellows you out a little bit but
at the same time I'm like I kind of
still want you to be a little crazy but
I was never upset to see Barbara I was
always always happy
to see Barbara and yeah it's yeah and
she's great in that scene where she were
like Gordon is hallucinating and she's
kind of like the elevator person I mean
she's just she's just great I just the
best that my top two are they are my top
two because of fun because ultimately
that is why I stuck with Gotham because
Gotham is fun it is insane psychotic fun
and the fact that she wasn't
consistently used as well as who is that
my number one was the only reason she
missed out at it so okay your number two
um yeah I just love him hard he's great
um and again I switched between him and
Alfred a lot at like pretty much I love
everyone I knew who my number one was
going in because I figure you're number
one yeah yeah I know you know I well I
knew yeah okay okay um so I like that he
has ties to fish in the underworld the
first season and that he's kind of like
you know guides Jim through the CB er
sides
his womanizing is funny his heavy
drinking is you know like he always he's
doing a little better but he always
brings himself down a little bit he kind
of the mess
yeah but he's he means well and he's the
nicest dirty cop he'll ever meet
yeah you really is he's a good balance
to Jim they have a great dynamic he just
just grows on me like I always it's Harv
he connects well with Lee as well like I
do love some of the scenes with Lee he
just had the good quieter understanding
of her and her effects on Gordon he's
got some good scenes to a lesser degree
with Selina and Bruce as well yeah I
mean like he doesn't have a bad rapport
with anybody no and again yeah one of
the beauty of this show they have care
that just all work together and all have
chemistry he's totally one of those
characters who you can put in a scene
with anybody you're gonna get something
good out of it yep um and I just love
that he lets Jim know he doesn't need to
be perfect because Jim is always trying
to be or morally upright and you're
right thing and now he's still there for
him and that he still loves him you know
and he looks great in hats he does so my
number one hold on I lost my card okay
there it is so number one yeah
so go ahead I just love him from the
moment he came on like oh who is this
this guy is great um just the mannerisms
he is unlike you
I never tired of watching him
self-sabotage watch him do it like I
it's so in character that like it's
always like how are you gonna get there
how are you gonna weasel your way out of
this how are you gonna ruin it for
yourself I'm like I could watch this for
like I could have watched it for three
more seasons at least I will never get
tired of him um again I agree there's
some storylines I like more than others
anything with him involving Edie
um but or anything where he's like super
close to death and like somehow like
escapes a car at the last moment which
he does a couple times yeah I'll I'll
keep watching that's you um and I never
feel like they dial back his character
he doesn't have the inconsistencies that
Selena does where I'm like this is not
really in character I don't know about
that his temper tantrums he throws
things don't go this way there are so
great because he seems to be getting it
together and collected and then he loses
it he just is great of manipulating
other characters he's like the keys he's
slithered to the top and then to
down and slid their back up Bob you know
what I like about his version of
manipulation is it's not sneaky like
everyone always knows that you know
you're playing me but you have you have
something yeah you you hold what I need
so I'm stuck with you but like I always
get the sense that Oswald thinks he's a
good manipulator when honestly he's just
a good strong armor I don't think even
realizes that about himself yeah he's
good violent pat death the passion that
he like this holds out um I uh I
actually I think even season one I was
like does he have a crush on Gordon and
then when it was confirmed in like
season two or three that like yes he
does actually like Edie I kind of called
early on I'm the keys yes this I know I
wish he and Ed would have gotten
together I understand it but I also kind
of love that they don't yeah I do too I
like that they continue to have this
affectionate yet uneasy whatever it is
they have and actually I kind of had
this conversation because he came up
when I talked to min Kobayashi last year
about asexual characters because I
talked about Oswald cuz in my head he's
asexual but per that discussion it is
possible he may be hobo homo-romantic
but asexual which I would buy okay I can
I can totally accept that too um yeah I
just he's great I'm not like again
didn't love season five but when he's
like putting on the monocle and the top
hat in that last episode I'm just like
yeah the monocle was a good look for him
so I love him love him love him
let me gush about Viktor Furbies yeah so
the reason Victor gets the top spot is
because of fun they're like as much as I
love Barbara there were times when I was
like there was literally never a time
when Victor showed up that I didn't have
the baby oh god yes like no matter what
he was doing whether he was killing
people robbing people shooting a bunch
of criminals cuz
have a license and then allowing a whole
bunch of other criminals who did have a
license to come in and broaden this
wedding and like each he just starts
firing up the gcpd from a formal way
Jose
hi Jim he takes so much joy in what he
does or one of my favorites when he
blows up the sirens and he's just
outside with rocket launcher ladies so
much oh call attention to like this is
what I'm gonna do yep this is what I'm
gonna do and you know you can stop me
from doing it he is very much a
supporting character he's never driving
the story nothing is build around him
but I don't think there was any
character that embodied the kind of fun
that I have with this show more
consistently yeah I just thought of him
and actor who's a really cool guy - yeah
he's great and I mean Gotham it's just
it was fun it wasn't fun that much just
you know what we shouldn't thrown the
like cards in the air but like we're
going wild but they didn't we can love
it for what it was yeah I will I will
choose to remember some like parts of
season five and for the most part
disregard and still have shows I love
Barbara to take it and Barbara being
wheeled away while in labor and shooting
two missiles oh yeah the healthy ban the
memory bank
but that's Gotham that's our oh that's
our list for our top ten favorite
characters from Gotham what do you folks
think what who is your favorite what's
your top ten what's your top 16 there's
a lot of characters and a lot of them
are very fun whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's also stuff
to do down there as well because there's
buttons and links and patriotic merch
and click on stuff it'll take you places
Charles I don't have to because at the
today folks you're the council I'm just
running the meetings sometimes with Liz
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]